hello everyone and welcome to today's
live session on getting started in 3d
models this is a live Q&A session to
enable attendees to ask questions about
growing and characterizing the 3d solid
models today's seminar is brought to you
by lab roots and sponsored by thermo
Fisher Scientific for more information
on growing 3d models or any educational
resources on 3d models please visit
www.iamnotapoodle.com
mark is our lead R and D scientists with
our 3d model program is directly
involved in the development of new cell
culture products for the growth and
characterization of 3d models and also
we have dr. Richard Josephson Richard is
the lead scientist and our neurobiology
group at Thermo Fisher Scientific and is
primarily focused on developing neuronal
3d models for the purposes of studying
neurological diseases such as
Parkinson's and other neurological
disorders
as mentioned our goal today is to
provide a forum for participants to ask
questions about growing and
characterizing 3d models we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want to submit a
question to just simply type the
question in the in the box that says ask
a question box and click on the send
button well answer as many questions as
we have time for if you have any trouble
scene or hearing the presentation or the
questions click on the support tab found
on the top right of the presentation
window or report your program by
clicking on the ask box located on the
far left of your screen
with that let's get started I first want
to hand it off to dr. mark Kennedy for a
quick introduction on 2d mouths to help
stimulate some questions mark thank you
Robert and thanks everyone for joining
so as Robert mentioned while folks are
busy answering their questions that they
would like us to try an answer into the
ask a question box I'm going to take
just a few minutes here to go over just
a couple of slides just some very
high-level background on 3d models to
sort of help us get started and
introduce the topic a little bit
so in the next couple of slides all I'm
going to briefly go over what it is to
just sort of highlight what they're
reinforced what Robert says is the sort
of the object over the the goal of this
this Q&A webinar session and then we'll
go through just a couple of slides on
the background and an intro to 3d cell
cultures we'll spend a couple of minutes
maybe the both of the time talking about
these are the key ingredients in making
3d models in general and in cell culture
type workflows and then we will turn it
over to the question session and we'll
do our best to answer as many questions
as we can
so as Robert mentioned really the point
of this webinar is to just create a open
form a live event if you will where you
know we we can interact with with
customers and people you know especially
people who are new to working in 3d
models or interested in getting started
in 3d models and perhaps we'll be able
to answer some questions maybe provide
some guidance or you know pass along
some lessons learned which sometimes are
hard lessons learned in working in these
types of workflows
so as I'm sure many folks who have have
joined to listen into this webinar and
hopefully participate some of this type
of information is probably not super new
news you know one of the things I want
to highlight here and as I'm sure people
are aware that three models are
definitely an emerging field in in cell
biology and particularly in in cancer
research over the last decade or so now
many new methods have been published
that detail ways of creating different
types of 3d models so things that are
either 3d spheroids that may be just a
single cell type that are cultured as a
cluster that provides some lot more in
vivo like cell interactions to more
complex models like organoid or stem
cell derived models that sort of are
often co-culture models or models made
up of different cell types and that are
architectural II and functionally
similar to an in vivo organ and so many
of these have been made of to represent
lots of different tissues in the body
you know including things like liver and
brain and intestine and a number of
others and these are also useful for for
studying different types of disease as
well and as it says here across the top
that it would appear at this point that
certainly the application of these
orbital models in particular is
certainly leading the charge and new
avenues of research in the cancer space
many of these models can be made from
different types of cells as I mentioned
you can make them sometimes from
different cancer cell lines that maybe
you're used to growing as a 2d model
layer in your lab or other types of
primary cells many of these models are
also induced pluripotent stem cell
derived models or embryonic stem cell
derived models but a lot of the models
are also derived from adult tissue
particularly stem
president stem cells in different organs
that reside in the in the epithelial
compartment of these organs are another
source of cells for making these these
types of models
and so as I've already sort of mentioned
or alluded to really when we're talking
about 3d models we're talking literally
a bit of 3d assembly or cluster of cells
that are obviously much different than
the traditional 2d model layer culture
systems that are the prevalent model
over many decades in cell biology and
biomedical research in general and you
know the switch to 3d models is really
driven by a desire to have cells
interact in a way that more mimics how
cells interact with each other in an in
vivo environment and this is led as I
mentioned to to the development of many
different types of spheroid and organoid
model systems and it's really also being
driven by different tissue engineering
approaches things like bio printing that
are allowing researchers now to to
generate these more complex assembly of
cells for for doing various types of
research and sort of strata straddling
both of these sort of broad classes of
models are things like traditional
co-cultures where maybe you mix two
different cell types that typically are
found adjacent to each other in an organ
in an actual animal model and also we
have the the tissue engineered organ on
a chip type approaches or sometimes
known as micro physiological systems
these are sometimes you know highly
engineered 2d model systems and in some
configurations and in some other
configurations they they may mimic more
like an organ or or spirit a model but
in general you know when we talk about
2d models and 3d models these would be
the broad classes of these models and
how we think about them so you know a
popular question if you're new to this
area or something you're just hearing
about more recently a question you may
have is wire researchers moving into the
system sort of what's all the hype about
and you know largely this is driven by
the desire to make better
better cell models for studying human
biology and what I mean by that is you
know traditional 2d model air cultures
although are incredibly helpful and have
been very informative over a very long
period of time and will continue to be
so into the future they are somewhat
overly simplistic and have less than
natural sort of cell-cell interactions
and this leads to changes in cellular
physiology that may not represent what
you know a particular cell behavior
actually looks like in in an in vivo
setting and so these 3d model systems
you know some of the interest in driving
researchers towards 3d models is the
sort of overcomes that as a limitation
of 2d models and put cells in a contact
in a context where you know they can
interact with with other cells in all
dimensions and interact with different
cell types in a spatially importer I
guess a spatially important way where
different cell types are arranged
similarly to the way in which they might
be in vivo and things like that and and
some of the results that have been
coming out of this is that when you
culture cells in this way the proteomes
and and transcriptome signatures of
cells in 3d models tend to look more
like the the signatures that you would
find when you look at in vivo cells
whereas it's quite commonly seen that in
2d model once cells are adapted to a 2d
culture system and and growing out
plastic that a lot of these gene and
protein expression signatures don't
always look like what the in vivo
situation looks like and so you know
these are some of the features of 3d
model systems that are driving people to
think of them as more physiologically
relevant cell culture models that's not
to say they art with their challenges of
course you know the many of the existing
workflows that researchers are sort of
been trained on and are comfortable with
are all
Toodee workflows and so being able to
adapt to culturing cells in 3d format is
is certainly it's challenging and
sometimes simply switching from one to
another is not overly straightforward
and this is particularly true when you
think about the types of assays that
that are available and the ability to
you know either lights a micro tissue
versus a mono layer cells or the ability
ability to label cells that are not on
the surface of a spheroid for for doing
imaging type analyses and and things of
that nature so there are certainly some
trade-offs and challenges still to be
met around workflow compatibility and
assays and and of course you know this
all leads to an increase in complexity
which is good but that also makes things
just in general more more challenging to
work with but I think as more and more
research is coming in on these models
that the growing consensus is probably
that you know it's the the added
challenges once you overcome them are
going to be worth it
and so this sort of naturally brings us
to to this next question particularly
for people who are new to to 3d models
is how do you get started and sort of
the short answer to this is it's the
same as you can start it with any cell
culture model system first of all you
need to identify what cell types you
want to work with what cell types are
important to you and you know there are
considerations then about how to sort of
QC yourself how do you know your cells
are useful or going to be helpful for an
assay and given that a lot of 3d
workflows tend to be very long and and
and somewhat more reagent intensive you
know making decisions about quality of
cells early on is very important to
contributing to the success of your
experiments and so you know an example
of this is looking at you know the
flurry potent status if you're working
with IPSC cells if you don't have a good
QC assessment of just how good your your
IPS CS are then every time you you form
a 3d model with these and differentiate
them into different types of of
organoids you know this is going to
contribute to a lot of the variability
that people see in sample a sample and
experiment to experiment so you know
being able to have QC tests that kind of
create a standardization if you will
within a workflow is definitely
something that that people need to be
aware of another obviously key
ingredient here for for culturing these
things are the use of major sometimes
matrices such as different types of
basement membrane extracts and also
specialized culture vessels or culture
vessels with specialized service
treatments so many 3d models in order to
make them sort of either grow in a 3d
sort of configuration and also to help
enhance their differentiation or
and physiological physiological
relevance sometimes cells are grown sort
of embedded or fully encased inside of a
basement membrane extract so instead of
growing cells on top of a thin coating
now you've got to deal with you know
this material that's typically
temperature sensitive so you have the
work on ice which limits scalability in
many ways so it's definitely another
thing that a researcher needs to be
aware of and then with the plastics a
number of these type of 3d model systems
may also require the use of certain
specialty plastics I think many of these
today sort of fall broadly in a category
of non adherent type plastics or super
low attachment plates and and this
allows cells to or health cells or her
convinces them to interact with each
other more so than trying to interact
with the surface because they can no
longer bond to the plastic of the
surface so it helps facilitate the
formation of 3d models in many different
types of systems and the third piece of
course are the media and supplementation
grow yourselves
I mean choosing good quality media
choosing growth factors and small
molecules and other types of supplements
that you know are reputable are
consistent from batch to batch and and
that sort of thing
is definitely something one needs to be
need to pay very close attention to and
sort of I think put a lot of weight
behind when you're sourcing materials
for for growing these types of models
and the last piece which is sort of
invisible and not really shown here
our assays I mean it's great if you can
grow these but if you can't assay them
and actually you know get something
useful that doesn't matte the end then
you know that that's a whole other set
of questions I think but but really what
I want to point out here about assays is
what I mentioned a couple slides ago is
there's a lot of assay optimization that
still needs to be done to work with 3d
models being able to label cells that
are you know more than just the cells
that are on the surface of the 3d model
is not always a trivial undertaking
especially
you're working with antibodies if you're
working with different types of chemical
probes for fluorescent labeling you know
I think those are little more manageable
right now based on existing protocols
with may only needs some some more
modern tweaks so that's the sort of food
for thought that I'd like to leave
everyone with and hopefully some of that
spur some some brain juices and and and
and some questions that you can submit
to us and with that this is the panel
that Robert introduced earlier we did
have a unfortunately a team member who
was unable to join us today but we would
like to turn it over to the QA and
Richard and Robert and I will do our
best to answer any questions that you
have
right thank you mark I really appreciate
the governor quick summary hopefully um
help stimulate some questions so as I
mentioned the whole goal of today's
session is really to have a live Q&A
session to help answer your questions so
if you do have any questions you'd like
to ask please do so now just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left your screen and we'll do our
best to answer as many questions as we
have time for there's already a quite a
few that have a have phone in so I'll do
my best to give us a little bit of
diversity and answer as many questions
as possible so with that let's start out
with a really general question for both
mark as well as Richard you know when
you first got started working in 3d
culture what were some of the challenges
that you had to overcome that are just
you know common practices that you do
today
maybe you could just give us a little
insight on that sure I can go first sure
um so it was a big adjustment and I
think initially um you know a couple of
things that I mentioned or at least one
of the things that I mentioned during
the during the preview for some of the
model that I first started working with
working with temperature sensitive
basement membrane extracts was sort of a
new level of difficulty that wasn't in
any of the traditional 2d workloads that
I had you know although I had used these
materials for you know creating coated
plates for growing different types of
pluripotent stem cells and and those
sorts of cells that require that kind of
coding you know working with with thick
error I should say highly viscous
basement membrane extracts was
definitely one of the challenges that I
was a little bit unprepared for and took
you know there's a little bit of a
learning curve there another sort of in
hindsight obvious challenge that came up
was the probably the first time that I
formed spheroids in a and a non-adherent
you bottom plate as you know i seated
myself and they form beautiful spheroid
and in a day or two
and decided okay it's time to change the
media and I think the plate into the
incubator I slide over to the hood I
turn on the aspirator I pick up the
plate and I go huh kind of lose all my
samples so so you know figuring of ways
to do a media change on a sample that is
not attached to the bottom of a plate
without losing your spheroids you know
that was something that you know in
hindsight is obviously a very important
challenge um but definitely something
that required a little extra effort and
sort of standard operating procedure
optimization in terms of making that
less of a headache wall while working
with these types of models right yeah
I'm going to go back a little further
than that even so I when I started
working in 3d models I thought it would
be easy to take my cells growing in 2d
dissociate them place them in suspension
and voila but it was not we were
initially trying to generate spheroid in
agitated culture flat agriculture plates
and I had to learn the hard way that be
you have to set your speed very
carefully when you're doing that and
control your media volume so that all
yourselves don't float to the center of
the well and aggregate and so the
solution to that was to start using the
low attachment 96-well you bottom plates
where you can where we found for neural
progenitors that you got a very linear
response to the number of cells that you
seated per well and the diameter of the
spirit that you would get out so that
made things much more predictable than
the mass culture of spheroid z' in a
shaking plate and then from that you
bottom plate you can then if you need to
encapsulate you can easily collect the 1
spheroid per well into a pipette and
encapsulate from there
right good you know both of you guys
kind of mentioned a little bit about the
challenges of media change and we
actually and turns out we have a
question about that
now you can span a little bit more you
know the question was sometimes we lose
our steroids during media changes do you
have any recommendations on how to
overcome some of those that but what I
do is not change 100% of the media at
anytime I'm generally I change the media
more often than it would in the 2d
culture but I change only half of it or
some set percentage of it each time so
you're leading leaving a small volume
and if you're spheroid sink to the
bottom that's enough generally to
protect you but I also I don't aspirate
pipette off at media carefully and yeah
there are definitely a couple of I guess
tricks to doing that I has Richard
mentioned you know doing it 50 or 75
percent media change is definitely the
way that that we went early on when when
we were working on this problem and
sometimes then when you're if you're
exchanging a whole different media
cocktail to another one you know you
just do it successively to dilute away
any any trace amounts of the era of the
first media you know for some of the
differentiation experiments that that
was probably important you know the
other things that we've done more
recently are to sort of adapt sort of I
guess you'd say it's automated equipment
but things that a lot of labs have like
like a plate washer that may be used
normally for for doing Eliezer's we
found that you know some of the models
of these systems have enough programming
capabilities that you can safely
aspirate to a certain level down into
the to the well that allows you to
change media on a full plate but then
the other thing that you know the only
other thing I would add on top of that
is you know make sure you do regular you
know QC don't just assume you have all
your samples when you get to the end so
typically what I do is every day when
whenever I have a media change day I
literally either it's
every single well or if you're lucky
enough to have a microscope with an
automated platform where you can you
know take a single brain filled snapshot
of every well that you can then look at
sort of in one picture and identify any
examples that are lost so you can sort
of monitor your samples accordingly but
but really the only other way
I would say as two as Richard mention is
to you know percent media change yeah
and sticking to the culture theme and
you guys both mentioned media as well
you guys are playing perfectly into the
set of questions that are coming in
congratulations
maybe you guys could come a little bit
more about the media formulations you
know our people primarily using the you
know the general media is like our pmid
ma'am do you need specialized media talk
to me a little bit about what movies are
used and and what what kind of media
formation what would have cheese really
good results
that's a good question I mean so 3d
field is still somewhat new and kind of
what that means to me is that you know
when you think about the 3d models that
are out there they've all been built on
the existing 2d model systems so so
frequently I think you will find that
you know the whatever basal media for
example that was being used to culture a
comparable cell in 2d was probably the
starting point for for anyone who is
making the switch to 3d and in many
cases that the media I think that has
stuck in some model systems there are
you know some advanced versions of these
media systems and this is particularly
important if you're trying to work in a
serum free environment so working
without fps using some of the advanced
media formulations was is definitely
something to consider and and I guess
the biggest change really is around the
way which we supplement the media and
the wealth at least when it comes to
stem cell derived models you know the
amount of supplementation of small
molecules and growth factors and that
sort of thing that's required in order
to culture the cell type of interest and
I think that's what those are some of
the things that I would my name
great thank you Mark preciate it
switching gears a little bit because I
mean after you have your model obviously
you'll want to characterize it so
there's obviously a couple questions
around what methods have you guys used
so far and characterizing your ma your
models and I think this is a question
for both Richard and mark so basically
if you get someone inside of what model
are sorry what assays or
characterization you've done your models
so far and if you have any tips or
tricks and when starting to use these
various characterization methods well
obviously in neuroscience the gold
standard is activity so we do record
from neurospheres honor our neural
spheroids on a micro electrode array
plate and it can be very very difficult
to get good results with that to even
plate steroids down we're finding is a a
tricky process so
so there aren't that many people who
have successfully recorded from from
spheroids you can't really stick a patch
clamp in and recording from them so
immunofluorescence is the is the other
major assay it can be very tricky
because neural spheroids are very very
dense to get any information about the
interior so there are protocols for
clearing the tissue that work but they
are extremely labor-intensive because
they go through successive dehydration
rehydration steps and then you need good
the right imaging equipment confocal to
get your data so a lot of people in the
neuroscience feel they're doing
single-cell sequencing or single-cell
RNA which requires you to dissociate the
spirit in the cover cells and sequence
RNA but that is tedious and expensive
so
it's very important to choose your assay
early on so that you can optimize for
with that from the very beginning and
the only other thing I would probably
add to that I mean we still do some of
your you know the types of routine qPCR
based assays are not necessarily going
to sequencing or single-cell sequencing
but you know we do have some evidence
even that if you're going to to lysa
a spheroid and I'm sure the larger the
spheroid gets the more significant this
problem is and it may vary admittedly
from cell type cell type but in some
cell types we do find that results are
highly variable if you you know use
certain types of lysis reagents some of
the tried tested and true methods seem
to work best you know using things like
tries all seem to be best at least in
our hands and sort of in addition to
that you know when possible we've sort
of taken to freeze-thaw event which you
know I guess in theory kind of creates a
little bit of a freeze fracture effect
when you go to use it this seems to be
giving us a better lysis of these of
these steroids when we want to do that
kind of work but you know and we've also
done other types of metabolic type
assays on hepatic models as well
different types of luminescent enzyme or
metabolic enzyme activity a say they
they generally work so a lot of the
reagents like that that are out there
can be optimized for for a saying these
reagents they just require more effort
than than the standard tuning version
right and have you guys either of you
guys tried any of the plate based
readouts or have you used your organizer
steroids and a play-based reader yet
um yes and I know some of our colleagues
in a different segment of thermo Fisher
have done a lot of this working with
spheroids and plate reader assays and
also in automated high content analysis
platforms certainly this is something
you can do there are considerations like
Richard brought up about you know there
may be a need to to look into you know
more labor-intensive methods such as
clearing in order to try and get more
signal from from within your samples
that that said there's there so you know
depending on your imaging equipment
there are still going to be limitations
to how many cell thicknesses you can
actually peer into a 3d model without
actually going and having samples either
cryo section or section and paraffin
blocks and analyzing that method but of
course that set shoots down any type of
throughput right on unless you're
looking at a small number of things you
know that that's the opposite of
probably what you're asking other plate
reader assays where cells are sort of
encapsulated in a bed of a basement
membrane extract we've done those with
you know standard viability type assays
like presto blue they also require
optimization around the length of time
for incubation with these reagents again
this seems to be directly related to
permeability of these through the BME
and also through you know a number of
cell layers and then being able to
detect that in a plate reader it
certainly does work but there's a you
know as with most assays there there's a
you know there's effort that needs to be
put in there to optimize you know time
of reagent treatments
self-seeding density which is not
trivial to make sure you're well within
a good range of being able to get
reliable readouts
yeah and just a quick question along
those lines when you guys do have to use
an ECM or a like a basement membrane
extract or something like that
do you guys typically feel that you have
to remove it in order to characterize
the model so that the ECM interfere with
any of the characterization methods
that you've experienced at least know
when I've done it with the neural
spheroids I can stain for at least the
outer surface of the Spirit through the
ECM I do find that fixing and para
formaldehyde tends to break down that
ECM and that's a known issue that para
formaldehyde will cause it to dissociate
so oftentimes they leave behind leave
the cells stained and left behind but
they'll be somewhat less organized than
they originally were
you've done some of that too we in in
sort of a mid throughput you know
working in 96-well format we've had
similar sort of challenges you know we
typically work with phenol red free
material where possible
I think this seems to help reduce any
you know sort of background signal that
that we may get from the ECM but you
know as Richard pointed out when you fix
these samples you know it's definitely
deep flavor eise's pair formaldehyde
will D polymerize some of these things
and and so that's a challenge we found
we can get around that by by coach or
post fixing with parrot mellowed and
glutaraldehyde the only challenge with
this is this potentially creates a high
levels of background so then it becomes
a trade up of you know sample loss
versus higher or poorer signal-to-noise
ratios there are some backgrounds to
press a reagent filter that I've tried
that seems to help at least at least in
certain assays that the the name of the
reagent is called something like
backdrop or something like that and
there's also a so called background
suppressor in a in one of the molecular
probes called psych want Dirac that also
seems to do a pretty good job of
suppressing that background so if you
are in a system where you don't want to
you don't want to remove cells from the
ECM if it's important that they stay
where they are that that seems to be a
trick that that seems to be working well
for us so far is the post fixing with
glutaraldehyde and then using this this
background suppressor
right thank you um a few questions about
your opinion questions so can you do you
think 3d bottles will ever replace
animal models and what do you think are
the kind of the current limitations of
3d models to be used to entirely mimic a
in vivo system questions that really I
know it's a loaded question I apologize
but it's a big one this is a very good
question
very important I don't know that will
they ever replace animal models but they
won't replace animal models anytime soon
and a lot of that has to do with the
aadmi considerations you have
administrators of the drug metabolism of
the drug but can that depend on many
different cell types and whereas where
you can make organoids that contain many
different cell types often times
proportions of those salt cuts are not
well controlled at this time so and you
need cells from many different tissues
you might need liver tissue in a brain
model to get really cover what happens
inside an animal yeah studying systemic
problems is definitely something that
you know maybe that's where you know
organs organize chips I guess that
approach you know may may have a future
um but I think I agree with Robert I all
right with with Richard that you know
what I think in time there may be a
reduction but the the likelihood of
eliminating seems seems to be a far-off
thing just because you know some of
these cells will continue to behave you
know there's still advantages to working
with some of these models in vivo for
example if the effect is somewhere else
you know a lot of these 3d model systems
don't contain any vasculature and you
know that that in and of itself is a
limitation to how big and probably how
complex current models can actually
become and you know so depending on the
your question of of interest and the
model system you're working in you know
that that could be a very important
limiting feature but in some models it
you know it may not be right I mean that
said that pharma companies are very
eager to eliminate animal testing as
much as possible very so you yeah so
it's easy to imagine a first wave of
testing and organized followed by more
focused testing and animals to save cost
okay great and then you know obviously
one of the challenges today I would
argue is just reproducibly inconsistency
growing the models right and we actually
have two great questions along those
lines and I'm going to bind them into
one um yeah what is the typical
percentage of organize that our success
successful from the total generating an
experiment and the second question and
it's very closely related and they were
asking how reproducible is the
production of neural organoids
starting from IPS es with today's
protocol so really they're both asking
what is the current success rate from
your experience what's normal and yeah
any comments you can add there
ah ah yeah I don't know how to answer
how successful the overall total is for
the knurl organoids so we've been we've
been making a lot of neural spheroid
starting from neural progenitor and that
is quite recent producible when you
start with a tool like the u bottom
place where you can get predictable
sizes receding but when you're starting
from IPSC it depends on the protocol so
you're choosing a protocol where you
start from embryo a body formation the
sizes of those are not necessarily as
controllable and the percentage of the
cells you want within is not as as
controllable so that adds quite a bit of
noise to reproducibility I think
that said we are we're working on some
products that will make reproducible PSC
models much more much easier to get in
3d in the near future
yeah and the only other thing I would
add to that I think is the the
consistency and reproducibility is also
wrapped up in the which type of neural
organoid you make you know some of the
published protocols are result in a
model that's you know far more complex
in terms of the number of cell types
that are present and so as you can
imagine you know these things started
with any sort of axes and it's one of
the cues that that's missing from say an
embryo that cells know where to develop
and help control proportions of cell
types and that sort of thing so you know
the more complex system you're trying to
make I think the more challenges you're
going to have with reproducibility and
consistency right yeah there's a panic
trade up yeah so the in reproducibility
exactly so as you slide down the scale
to somewhat less complex where maybe
you're only you know modeling cortical
Genesis or something like that where you
know while still obviously very complex
and lots of cell types it's still a
reduction in cell types and some of the
published models that we've seen at
least on the face of it they seem to be
more reproducible and you know depending
on what research question you're asking
you know level of complexity that you
need is probably just an important
consideration as well or for that very
reason that they you may struggle to get
enough samples that are consistent if
you're working with a more complex model
but if you don't need that complex model
you may just get better data with with a
somewhat more simplified version of the
of that type of an organized something
that you know represents a smaller
region of a given tissue
right and I would imagine success rate
would vary based upon the model yourself
you're looking at right is even starting
from the cell cells that you initially
use to form the model yeah absolutely
yeah no there are definitely lots of
things that contribute to it you know
the starting the you know I'm sure
there's variability between especially
with IPSC lines yes I'm sure there is
variability with embryonic stem cell
lines as well
some of them have propensity z' work too
you know they they like and they seem to
differentiate into certain lineages a
little better than others so you know
the if you're looking at sample sample
or experiment to experiment or so on
cell line there are different degrees of
different types of reproducibility and
consistency concerns that you know I
think a researcher needs to pay very
close attention to to make you know sort
of broader claims around experimental
results yeah and bases and we have a
question here about variability within a
plate so just based upon your experience
does the 3d structures vary a lot from
well to well within your different
cultures that you tried again it may be
tissue specific or model specific just
curious on your experiences
I mean at least for me I don't want to
speak for Richard for me I mean similar
to the previous question right the the
some of that reproducibility and
architecture is related to you know you
know difficulty your inability to
control proportions of cell types and so
you know they may not necessarily look
exactly the same if you've got varying
numbers of cell type a cell type B and
cell type C so that you know it's hard
to answer sort of specifically but that
that's that would that's what I would
say
great alright
okay shifting gears a little bit here
your experiences that using 3d printing
to make 3d cell models and any insights
you can share there
that's that's a good one yeah so I've
not done a lot with bioprinting just yet
you know it's certainly a growing area
of interest you know it's I think to
date it seems to reside a little more on
the engineering theory official
engineering side of biomedical research
and and you know and I guess kind of
what I mean by that it's a lot of the
work with bioprinting is probably done
from an engineer's perspective which in
and of itself is very interesting and
it's a you know potentially a great way
to control some of the consistency
problems where you know with with
reasonably good resolution you can you
know control for architecture by
printing you know a certain number of
cell types and a specific geography or
spatial arrangement and do that much
more reproducibly than some of these
other self-organizing models like you
get in organized systems I would say you
know it still seems to be a bit of a new
field while there are you know people
making headway in the space and you know
a lot of it is still very much I think
on the discover it and maybe discovery
is the wrong side but still on a
development side so you know for me it's
still sort of a I'm keeping a close eye
on it with lots of interest but not a
lot of practical experience in that
field yet all right a couple questions
here about what's ECMs we have used and
been successful with especially for
organoids
Oh primarily we've used the gel checks
for encapsulation of swords or organized
and had pretty good success with that it
seems to be to work fairly
reproducibility reproducible
Marcus tried a few things more than
answered so yes mostly it's been in that
class of products though you know gel
Traxxas is you know maybe for obvious
reasons is our go-to but you know the
other comparable project products that
are on the market you know we we
basically seen you know very similar
results regardless of which version
you're using at least within the the
model systems that we've been exploring
so you know that the class of basement
membrane extract is you know the bulk of
where we've done our work a little bit
with collagen as well that's probably
you know more well studied and then you
know to relatively define reagent
compared to the basement membrane
extracts you know we've had some success
there as well but largely we've been
working with basement membrane extracts
with you know comparable results across
all technologies right yeah we've also
had for the neural spirits when we want
to attach them at good success with
laminate
especially for trying to attach them to
multi electrode array the laminin is
very helpful
yeah and and I am I know I've had this
question before and I see it again now
on our list do so for systems that don't
use or scaffold free that are used
something like a altra low attachment
plate or a hanging drop of apparatus
today
then those several rates spheroids
eventually secrete their own ECM or do
you have any insights there I think it
depends on what type themselves and the
spheroid
there was a presentation neuroscience
meeting last year where somebody showed
sections of neural organoids they were
making that we're secreting laminate
laminin was present as a halo around the
outside of the peridot that was very
striking
okay good and then we also have a
question about where we obtain our cells
for 3d culture is it always do we always
frequently source from patient biopsies
or where we're working one go to get
cells
yeah so I guess I can add a little bit
here you know there are a number of
different sources that that one can go
to for sells for different types of 3d
models you know there are you know a
number of different cancer cell lines
sort of the the workhorses and in many
labs quite a number of them have been
shown in recent years to you know be
with a self-assemble into some sort of
organ or a spheroid type culture that
you know behaves differently than its 2d
counterpart does so you know that's one
source of cells there are different
types of primary cells that that people
have been using as well and I think
there's a growing popularity in in the
use of using primary human hepatocytes
and animal derived pata sites as well so
these being the you know the adult pata
sites these these are not delivered of
cells and while there are there is batch
to batch or isolation isolation donor to
donor variability you know companies are
qualifying these cells to sort of take
that burden away from customers at least
to show that you know you can culture
these in a round bottom or hanging
dropper or one of these types of formats
and form primary cell steroids as well
and you know that's a subject that's
obviously very important in drug
discovery otherwise you know IPS es are
very commonly used so kind of wherever
you get your IPS ES or whether you
derive them yourself I'm sure there is
some variability in the efficacy we've
seen a little bit of that between some
of the embryonic stem cells that I've
worked with in recent years but in
general you know they they work
sometimes there are tricks that you can
apply to help convince them if you will
to aggregate a little more efficiently
you know sometimes the use of things
like rock and hibbett ER or buy to sell
in certain cell types is something that
may help there and of course the other
there's a very significant population of
publications now that have demonstrated
you know the ability to isolate cells
from
progenitor and stem cells from from
primary tissue whether animal derived or
human tissue derive other human
resections or or patient biopsies and
this can be either normal cells or they
can be a cancerous tumor cells tumor
derived cells where you can basically
you know grow pieces of the tumor ex
vivo in a way that is very analogous to
to making PDX models and mice only the
benefit is you don't need any monies so
really there's a wide range of cell
types or cell sources that people can
can look into further their cell of
interest and you know there are quite a
number of I think public bio banking
efforts underway to help tackle that and
to become a resource or repository for
researchers who may not have access to
patient tissue and things like that to
to be able to source these cells as well
right thank you
all right um a question around your
experiences with kidney organoid
cultures and if you ran into any
problems one our challenges when growing
kidney organoids
I haven't done that I've done IPSC
derived kidney organized once in the
past you know that they're I free and
how many they're they're a few of
similar but different public protocols
is they're the ones that I've tried
actually worked pretty well I think
I forget which lab did the original
publication off the top of my head you
know these are tricky in a sense because
they're probably one of the more complex
organs in terms of number of cell types
that would normally exist I don't know
how I'm not sure how many of those cell
types people have been able to generate
in a meaningful way but you know the
published protocol is generating you
know proximal tubules cells
collecting duct cells you know basically
a good part of that piece of the kidney
the protocol were relatively reagent
like compared to many other organelles
that I've worked with and you know they
work reasonably well
right okay and then I'm going to combine
two different questions here together a
couple questions around genome editing
of your organized models as well as gene
silencing and just curious on your
experiences and editing cells that are
virtually used for 3d models or even
editing the 3d models or felt or if you
have any guidance or advice in that
arena yeah I don't think that editing
the 3d models themselves is that common
approach because you end up editing
cells on the outside and not the inside
but it is very common to generate edited
IPSC line and then form organoids from
that I'm currently doing organoids from
some edited lines IPSC lines and there
seem to be a good deal of
reproducibility from line to line doing
that so maybe that I think that with
starting from the initial IPSC line is
probably the way to go yeah and that's
the approach that I've seen taken as
well to generate sort of disease
relevant mutations or to make isogenic
lines whether their IPs see lines from
patients or you know to make other
disease or or normal controls and also
in the adult stem cell field you know
they're they're growing reports on being
able to do that but as Richard said I
think starting doing the gene editing in
the singular eyes or near singular eyes
cells before you grow the organizers
it's going to be the most effective
effective approach otherwise you're
going to get as we're going to said
you're going to end up with cells you're
going to end up with a mosaic basically
where only the outer cells or some
percentage of the inner cells are the
ones being gene edited and you know
given that these models may have
multiple cell types they may not even be
the cell type that you want edited so if
you were to do it starting at the 3d
stage here you know you may not be
setting yourself up for success
definitely start with
the starting population
great and I think we only have time for
one last question so I'll ask it to both
of music both mark and Richard same
question to you guys if you had one tip
for anyone who's brand-new starting in
3d culture today what would it be the
hard one I know my Jim is not a very
well the two that I would give I guess
based on my experience is planned
planned plan right
you know these protocols tend to be
pretty long there you know for for a lot
of people if you know if you've been
working in a lab for a while but working
with I guess what today we would call
more traditional models and you're
trying to make the switch to a 3d model
then you know there is a little bit of a
learning curve on these things and you
know being able to adopt these culture
systems they're you know it's a
different way of looking at cell the
analysis you know it's more challenging
so planning ahead thinking about you
know the amount of reagents because
these do tend to be more reagent
intensive as well so thinking about the
amount of reagents of certain growth
factors you know given that you see lots
a lot variability sometimes in these
types of reagents or if you need to
prepare condition media you know there's
a I tend to think that you know spending
more time on the prep work on the
planning is what I would recommend to
people and sort of you know be the
second piece of that is I think there's
a saying I heard some time ago that you
know six months in the library care week
in the library can save you six months
in the lab so this type of planning
ahead and making sure you know you're
you're not just doing something because
you can but you know right applying that
level of focus and forethought is a when
possible at least it's definitely what I
would say to people right I think you
also need to think hard about how you're
going to maintain the viability of your
cells because it can be much more
challenging with diffusion limits keep a
spirit alive or an organized alive so
you need to figure out how you're going
to try to keep them small keep them
well-fed which may require more frequent
feeding than you're used to in 2d so it
can be quite labor-intensive over a long
period of time
great excellent well thank you both you
know we're out of time so I'll have to
end the conversation there but um before
we go I'd like to thank dr. Kennedy and
dr. Josephson for your for their time
today as well as the audience for
joining us today in their long list of
questions we did not get to all the
questions that were submitted so if you
do have any questions that were
unanswered we will be reaching out to
you or you can feel free to reach out to
your thermo Fisher representative to
help answer that so um so in addition to
thanking mark and and Richard also want
to thank lab roots and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for the webcast
today and the webcast can be viewed on
demand lab roots will alert you when the
email email when it's available for
replay and of course we encourage you to
share this email with your colleagues or
anyone who has missed the event today so
um thank you very much for attending and
until next time thank you and goodbye
you